that you have signed with Jordan
when you knew when you had the
opportunity to sign with Jordan was it
like an immediate man yeah I'm about to
sign with Jordan or was it like I don't
know just yet I have a couple of other
opportunities like you know what was it
for you so for me I was with Nike right
before I was a Jordan so it was really a
hard decision to move from Nike because
Nike started throwing out some stuff
yeah and they took care of you too and
they definitely always took care of me
too but like they started like
and I was like
yeah it's hard it's hard but I always
want to assignment Jordan and I had like
a little have a little Jordan story for
me yeah I always grew up on and that's
why I always wanted to sign with Jordan
okay tell them about the story
all right so I was 10 years old
uh Michael Jordan had a celebrity
softball game in the Bahamas okay
Atlantis my stepdad's one of was one of
the umpires of the thing so I got to go
our whole Little League was there this
and that Jordan's sneaking out of the
back I asked him for autograph
he looks at me he turns around and says
one day make me want your autographed
kid and just walks off
um like nothing else like he didn't even
budge
just walks off one day make me want your
autograph yeah what'd you have would you
have to I had a picture of him like a
okay Jordan just wanted him to sign it
yeah like that's the only person like
Jeter was there you know the whole
Yankees was there A-Rod CCC okay yeah I
think he brought out some football
players Fitzgerald
uh Ben Roethlisberger was there who he
hit a bomb I'm surprised oh okay that's
why I remember he was there but like
yeah Johnny Damon those guys was there
and I was like hey let me try and you
know get a signature whatever didn't get
it he just like turned it back and told
me that and just walked off so like I
have to like go and tell him that
because now that I'm Jordan yeah he has
my autograph
that's really why I didn't really wanted
it so did do you feel like
do you do you feel like you used that
moment to uh
fuel you and all that's not really the
right word but do you feel like you use
that moment
to now
to what the help you get to where you
are oh yeah 100 I think I use that like
for my first got in professional
baseball I told my agent that and he's
still my agent now from I was saying
16-17 to now he's been my agent and like
that was like one of the main things
that we work to is to get this Jordan
deal because like that's the number one
thing I was one one oh you so you've won
even with when you were with Nike yeah
you wanted to get to Jordan oh yeah okay